be over the past 300 years by author
Orlando [ __ ] beginning with the building
of st. Petersburg Flags interweaves
great works with cultural and artistic
events through the challenges of the
Soviet and post-soviet regimes the
program runs about an hour good
afternoon everybody on behalf of
Kennan's - director blair ruble I
welcome you to the Woodrow Wilson Center
my name is Joseph Dresden and I am a
program associate with the Kenan
Institute before we begin I'd like to
announce some upcoming events for next
week on Monday November 4th floated
above ik a visiting scholar at the
University of Maryland College Park and
a former accountant stood regional
exchange Scholar will give a
presentation on us Ukraine relations and
in the new security environment later
that week on November 7th that's a
Thursday
James Duran professor emeritus
Department history of Canisius College
will speak on Putin's economic
straightjacket austere budgeting in a
poor state today we are privileged to
host a book launch for Natasha's dance a
cultural history of Russia written by
Orlando Sykes professor of history at
Birkbeck College of London University
here is a copy of the book and there are
copies for sale outside
professor Flags has agreed to sign books
purchased here after this session
professor Sykes is one of the foremost
authorities on Russian history and his
book on the Russian Revolution a
people's tragedy is the recipient of the
Wolfson Prize for history and the Los
Angeles Times Book Prize among others
his newest book
Natasha's dance has been met with early
widespread acclaim from the New York
Times Book Review The New York Review of
Books Publishers Weekly
Kirkus Reviews only tame a few it is a
sweeping panorama of Russian culture and
history from the founding of st.
Petersburg Russia's window to the west
to the Brezhnev era and composer Igor
Stravinsky's emotional return to his
homeland from fifty years of Exile it is
also a search to understand rush
through pulling on strings of history
poetry folklore customs and rituals
landscape music and of course a certain
famous dance from Russian literature we
are pleased to have professor fives with
us here today and we look forward to
hearing his thoughts on his ambitious
new work jay-z thank you very much I
take it I'm audible can you see that
picture at the back no we really good
dinner Lazar that's great thank you very
much yes well thank you for that Joseph
it's a pleasure to be here and as you
say the book is made up of a lot of
different components trying to get at
something quite subtle and elusive
indeed namely a sensibility which one
could place at the heart of something we
would call culture whatever that is and
I would like to try and unpack both
those concepts a bit today and having
finished the book and not really knowing
how to frame it my editor in America
said well why don't you focus on
something rather beautiful and since the
book had always really been about trying
to engage with the beauty that I've
always found in Russia I decided to go
to the Natasha dancing scene because it
was always a scene I'd loved and Natasha
was always someone I'd been in love with
and in fact as I began to think about it
more and more it was a very useful way
to introduce some of the themes of the
book and also some of the questions
about how one can write a cultural
history at all no doubt the scene is
known to all of you here I'm sure but
let me just recap very briefly on it
it's that moment in war and peace when
Natasha Rostova and her brother Nikolai
find themselves at the end of days
hunting in the woods being invited back
to their uncle's cabin it's not really
clear whether he is an uncle of the
Rostov family uncle appears in inverted
commas but he lives there retired army
captain from civil service or with a
woman called an Neesha who's introduced
as his housekeeper but it becomes clear
from the looks between them that she's
also some sort of unofficial wife and
she brings in trey laden with lots of
Russian goodies cherry brandy vodka
various flavors and then Natasha hears
the strains of a balalaika being played
from a back room where the hunting serfs
are and uncle realizes she's curious and
calls for his battle his guitar to be
brought out and he begins to play a
popular melody came a maiden down the
street and calls on the Tasha to dance
and let me just read briefly from that
scene now they're nice he exclaimed
waving to Natasha the hand that had just
struck a chord
Natasha threw off the shawl from her
shoulders ran forward to face uncle and
setting her arms akimbo also made a
motion with her shoulders and struck an
attitude where how and when had this
young countess educated by an émigré
French governess imbibed from the
Russian there she breathed that spirit
and obtained that manner which the part
of shell would one would have supposed
long ago have her faced but the spirit
and the movements were those inimitable
and unteachable Russian ones that uncle
had expected of her
as soon as she had struck her pose and
smiled triumphantly proudly ah and with
slime element
she had the fear that had first seized
Nikolai and the others that she might
not do the right thing was at an end
and they were all already admiring her
she did the right thing with such
precision such complete precision that
an easier Feodorovna who had at once
handed her the handkerchief she needed
for the dance had tears in her eyes
there she laughed as she watched her
slim graceful countess reared in silks
and Velvets and so different from
herself who yet was able to understand
all that was in uneasier and in and
easiest father and mother and armed and
in every Russian man and woman
so we could ask what enabled Natasha to
pick up so instinctively the rhythms of
the dance
how could she step so easily into this
village culture from which by education
and social class she was so obviously
far removed are we to suppose as Tolstoy
does in this romantic and one might add
highly unlikely scene the donation such
as Russia maybe Hill together by the
unseen threads of a native sensibility
this then is the question that I've
tried to tackle and the subject of the
book is not just as a cultural history
great creative works of art like warm
peace but cultural artifacts from the
folk embroidery of Natasha shawl to the
musical conventions of the peasant dance
and its folklore and religion and social
customs and beliefs as well what I
wanted to do was to explore the way that
music art and literature all the great
art forms became entangled with custom
and social belief in the apprehension
and artistic articulation of what we
call national identity I wanted to
explain more over how these artistic
myths of Russia became powerful
political ideas that organize society
Russian culture it seems to me needs
historians to make these broad
multidisciplinary links if you think
about it nowhere else have the arts
being quite so entangled in social
movements and ideas because basically
for the past 200 years or so the Arts in
Russia have served as a main arena for
political philosophical and religious
debate in the absence of a parliament or
a Free Press or even a free church as
tell story explained in a few words
about war and peace the great artistic
prose works of the 19th century we're
not meant as novels in the European
sense they were huge poetic structures
for symbolic contemplation not unlike a
Nikon laboratories in which to test
ideas
and like science or religion they were
animated by the search for truth but the
overarching theme of all these words
with a great majority of them it seems
to me was the theme of Russia itself its
history and destiny spiritual essence
it's the place in the world in a way
that was extraordinary
if not unique to Russia the country's
artistic energy was almost wholly given
to the quest to grasp the idea of its
nationality nowhere has the artist been
quite so burdened with the task of
national leadership and for that very
reason nowhere has the artist been more
feared and persecuted by the state
alienated from official Russia by their
politics from peasant Russia by their
education Russia's artists from roughly
the 1820s and 30s onwards took it on
themselves to create a national
community through values and ideas of
literature and art and at the center of
many of their works is the question of
what it means to be a Russian where was
the true Russia in Europe or in Asia in
Petersburg or in Moscow in the palaces
of the Tsar's or in the muddy one Street
Village where Natasha's uncle lived
these then were the questions that
preoccupied not just every serious
writer poet musician artist but many
folk lawyers and indeed many geologists
and archaeologists in that Golden Age of
Russian culture from the age of Pushkin
to the age of Pasternak and what I've
tried to do is to take all of these
manifestations together make links
between them to try to come up with a
history of ideas and attitudes using
works of art not as a window onto life
but as a as a record of belief or
notions of the nation by which Russia
came to understand itself because I
think if we look carefully at these we
can use them as a window on a nation's
inner life
now Natasha's dancing scene is one such
opening at its heart is the encounter
the encounter that runs right through
Natasha's dance the book that I've
written the encounter between two
entirely different worlds the European
culture of the upper classes and the
native or Russian culture of the
peasantry from the beginning of the 18th
century the aristocracy especially
instant Petersburg less so but still in
the provinces two had emerged itself in
the culture of the West
it built European palaces it bought
imported clothes and furniture it
adopted foreign manners and conventions
secular ideas and attitudes it read
foreign books it imitated Western works
of art and it spoke in French and
English better on the whole than it
spoke its native tongue a question I
think a terribly important question
about language which we might return to
when we come to open discussion this
then was the cosmopolitan culture of
Tolstoy his own childhood which he
placed at the center of war and peace as
I say then this creative tension between
the high and low culture of Russia is I
think the driving force of so much of
that Russian cultural Renaissance of the
19th and early 20th centuries there was
an obsessive quest by artists like
Tolstoy to capture apprehend encapsulate
express the unique features of this
native culture and to find the common
threads whether that be in language and
custom in religious belief or in what
Hertz and called the feudal bonds of
affection uniting the noblemen with the
serf domestics that might bind Russia's
elites with the Russian people the war
of 1812 was the first moment when these
two cultures Russia's high and low
culture in a sense began to move
together in a national formation and
that's I suppose why Tolstoy focused war
and peace as a sort of
EPIK at that time stowed by the
patriotic spirit of their serfs the
aristocracy of Natasha's generation
began to break free from the farm
conventions of their society and search
for a new nation based on Russian
principles now clearly that was
something going on throughout Europe
they were influenced terribly by the
romantic writers of Germany in this
endeavor but there were but there was a
particular political dimension to that
quest for Russian as' which so obviously
stemmed from the great social divide in
Russia at the time and it added a
particular flavour to the Russian
national moment we can see this return
to native ways in this print by adolphe
Liguria which is as you all know doubt
no in the Winter Palace view of the
White Hall in the Winter Palace dated
1838 and you can see dimly albeit on the
left Russian society ladies coming to a
ball wearing a satyr fan had a
traditional Russian headdress we also
know from records of about this time the
plea ASCO the Russian or polish dance
began to appear at society balls even in
the Winter Palace alongside the
traditional euro French mazurkas waltzes
such as antosha herself danced in war
and peace and indeed like Natasha there
were many noble women who had learned to
dance the PS cone other Russian dances
by this linkers Hertz in put it with the
serfs who had brought them up and there
were in society women who made quite a
name for themselves in the eighteen
thirties and forties dancing in a very
virtuoso manner the traditional Russian
dance at society balls we can see it too
in fashion as in this portrait by Vasily
through peanin of Pushkin dated 1827
where the great poet is pictured in a
harlot in the traditional Russian such a
splendid institution isn't it the how
that the the housecoat which is also
form
enough to receive guests so here we have
the portrait of a of a thoroughly
Europeanized russian gentleman who's
perfectly at ease with the customs of
his native land at the same time as
Tolstoy reminds us throughout warm peace
Russians were switching in society in
the salons and the ballrooms in in their
own boudoirs and reception rooms they
were switching from speaking French -
speaking Russian and it was a long
protracted process not it didn't happen
quite as quickly as tell story with
great artistic license suggests
immediately after 1812 and it was
obviously going to be a very difficult
transition because so many Russian words
for individual expression I mean
basically rush on salon language was
incredibly gala sized with most words
adapted or near logicians from the
French you might recall that scene in
one piece where it princess hell ends a
salon where they decide that there'll be
a forfeit paid for everybody who speaks
in a French word but since they can't
remember or think of a Russian word for
forfeit that they say that there'd have
to be a forfeiture and we see from about
this time that Russian grammar begins to
enter into the curriculum of of many
petersburg noble children from from
about the eighteen twenty eighteen tens
and twenties the Russians began to make
a thing of eating Russian foods as well
and we see the first Russian cookbook
published only as late as the 1810s
and we see changes in interior design my
own favorite example is out of chaos
demand Tolstoy who has his famous Palace
on the English embankment in some
petersburg and the grand reception rooms
eyes you might expect them in the sort
of classical Rococo style with lots of
marble and floor-to-ceiling mirrors but
in the private more intimate setting of
the bedroom he uses Karelian woods and
indeed there's a bedroom which is
entirely lined with a curry
woods as if it's some sort of peasant
log cabin many noblemen like Natasha's
uncle it would seem renounce the service
character of st. Petersburg altogether
and try to live a simpler or as they saw
it more Russian way of life with the
peasantry on their estates and there
were even noblemen who lived with
peasant light wives as as Natasha's
uncle did one of them the richest man in
Russia at the time with perhaps a
million serfs namely count Nikolai
Petrovich shut him eh if he's shocked
society in eighteen one by marrying this
woman here Pastore a gem xu gova who was
a what had been until just before the
marriage a serf singer in shedding
natives private opera Tolstoy himself
are we know fell in love with a serf on
his estate and his feelings for aksinya
Bezique honor which he described to
teddy gain of another man by the way who
had fathered children of by serf women
were not those as to gainers might have
been the feelings of a stag but as
Tolstoy put it to gain of the feelings
of a husband for a wife and there are
now documents suggesting that he even
continue to see Bezique honor after he'd
married sophia bears in the early 1860s
and there's that interesting story the
the devil written in I think 1889 where
the narrator imagines what it might have
been like if instead of marrying a
noblewoman he had actually married the
the peasant woman that he'd loved and
who appears cleaning the floors and
before his wife and there's that moment
of recognition between wife and former
lover
okay the interaction between these two
cultural worlds which was so distinct in
so many ways the educated Europeanized
culture of the upper classes and the
village culture of the peasantry this
interaction had a crucial influence on
the national
and on all the major forms of art in the
nineteenth century and as I say that
interaction is a major theme of
Natasha's dance but the story which I
tell is not meant to suggest that a
single national culture emerged as a
result Russia was obviously too complex
too too big to will define
geographically much too divided socially
and politically for a single national
culture to be passed off as the sort of
national heritage and moreover I would
say there was no authentic village
culture of the sort imagined by Tolstoy
in the dancing scene I mean if you think
about the elements in it the melody -
which Natasha dances it's not a folk
tune as far as we can tell came a Maidan
down the street might have began as a
folk tune but it actually came down to
the village as a popular melody in sheet
music so like so many folk tunes they
were popularized having gone through the
towns and coming back into the
countryside indeed are there any really
genuine folk tunes I mean most they're
probably only about four or five folk
tunes in the whole of Europe and they
just get circulated around the place and
coming coming in and out of urban
societies and change them back into the
countryside other elements of the
village culture Toffler pictured may
have come to Russia one might think from
the Asiatic steppe courtesy of the
Mongol horsemen who ruled indirectly
over Russia from the 13th to the 15th
century and then who stayed in Russia
for the most part as agriculturalists
pastoralists traders and indeed as I'm
sure you know many of them entering into
the aristocracy itself Natasha Shah was
almost certainly of Persian origin
although from the 1820s there were a
number of peasant factories in the
Russian provinces producing you know
Pleasant type shawls but often copying
oriental patterns to cater to the taste
of society ladies in the towns who
couldn't afford or who couldn't get
quick access to a Persian shawl the
balalaika that uncle plays was descended
musical ethnographers tellers from the
dom bro a guitar of Central Asian or
and a guitar which also spawned as one
of its legacies the goose Lee which you
see here sort of hurdy-gurdy used in
much folk music throughout Russia and
tuned usually to five strings because so
some musical ethnographers of the late
19th century argued five string because
it basically much of Russian folk music
was similar to the or aligned to the
pentatonic or five tone indo-chinese
scale so you see in fact from the even
as early as the 1860s composers like
Berle a curative and for a while
rimsky-korsakov trying to a sort of
oriental eyes the Russian music style by
writing elements of it in in the
pentatonic scale I think the first
example of it is about 1868 with the
tomato sweet the piano suite by Bella
Kiev Natasha's dance itself for we know
may have come from Asia I mean if you
think about the Russian tradition of
dancing in lines and circles rather than
in pairs it doesn't have much in common
with with the waltz and etosha would
have danced at the ball and moreover the
the the movements don't come from the
body as a whole they come from the
shoulders from the hands the subtle dole
light movements of the head now during
the late nineteenth century there was a
growing interest in this possible
Asiatic influence on on Russian folk
culture and it began around about the
1870s with a great nationalist critic
Vladimir Stas of who made a study both
of Russian ornaments and of the Russian
folk epics epic tales the B Leonie and
he said that both of them argue that
both of them were in fact just ratified
forms of oriental patterns and this so
he would argue for example the great
tales like sad Cohn Ilya Muromets which
for the slava files were of course you
know the classic example of Russia's
homegrown
culture had in fact come to Russia
courtesy of traders and warriors and and
the rest and been ratified with elements
from Russian life added to them and he
based this notion on a theory of culture
which I think to a large extent I would
subscribe to myself which is that
actually cultures don't just grow from
the soil so to speak they are borrowed
and this was tiered or been phase theory
of cultural borrowing that actually most
cultures work by by interchange and that
all cultures are actually much more
international than the people who who
advocates their preservation or put them
at the center of their nationalist
politics would advocate well as as I've
suggested then the slava files in the
mythological school who were closely
aligned with the Slaven files took great
offense at stats of x' theories and we
can return to that a question time
perhaps but i but uh stops theories had
enormous influence on on on a number of
russian artists at the turn of the
century none more so than nikolai Rarick
the painter who as you probably know was
also an archaeologist involved in the
excavation of city and burial mounds in
the crimea whose treasures can now be
found in the Winter Palace itself and
stance of sorry I think about a rare
--is-- had this idea of you know sort of
Scythian ruse as being something that he
could concoct really out of elements
that he would have borrowed from Eastern
patterns themselves along with Rory
Stravinsky took to these series of the
Eurasian element in Russian culture and
indeed in the 1920s became a fully
fledged member of the Eurasian his
circle and here we can see him in
nineteen nine Stravinsky on the Left
they're transcribing a folk song being
played but are a song by a ghostly
player on the steps of his estate at
Ostia log which is
now I believe in Lithuania with his
mother holding his son there teared or
in her arms and Stravinsky was obviously
very interested in trying to capture the
elements of Russian folk song which he
increasingly came to see is actually
quite distinct from the European folk
song tradition particularly in terms of
its rhythms with his discovery courtesy
of musical ethnographers in the 1890s
that the song accentuation of Russian
language was much freer and could be
quite different from the spoken
accentuation of Russian poetry or
language and this clearly gave
Stravinsky the endless possibility to
introduce written greater rhythmic
freedom to his music and along with
Rarick he came to this conception I
think of the Rite of Spring in in a sort
of Scythian mold here we're going to
show some of the distinct non-european
elements of Russian culture at play so
we can see it for example here is rarest
painting the idols from 19:1 which shows
you this sort of fantasy of of Neolithic
Russia with elements from those sort of
totems that Rarick would have borrowed
quite directly from Stas of zone
ethnographic work here Oates - stass of
it at this period asking him for advice
about what you know what sort of motifs
would have been used in Neolithic Russia
and Stancil wrote back to him say we'll
just copy it from what you can find in
tartar motifs or Persian motifs today
because quote where is my quote it says
stash off said basically ancient Russia
and the ancient East are the same thing
we can see it too in the choreography
here's rarest costumes for the Rite of
Spring with it's not particularly clear
here but but Rarick did introduced
copies of tartar jewelry to the
headdress and you know the heavy
necklaces and things like that
which directly copied by Rory from from
from tartar collections
and we can see it in the choreography
with their you see their feet turned in
and their elbows sticking out in
contravention of all the basic rules of
classical ballet which are supposed to
emphasize lightness and movement here
the choreography of fer keenan in the
Rite of Spring is clearly emphasizing
the immobility of the dancers their
heaviness or kneepad vision assess the
musical term for that immobility goes
and an inability which clearly lies at
the heart of the explosive energy of the
music in the Rite of Spring okay why
this excursion into this Asiatic corner
because essentially what I've tried to
put to you is that there is no authentic
culture at the heart of the village seen
pictured by Tolstoy in war and peace
that in fact as in most cultures I would
argue so much of Russian culture was in
fact imported and borrowed from abroad
and then adapted in various ways but if
that's the case that there's no
authentic ethnographic culture if it is
the case that much of any culture is in
fact invented then all we have our
mythic images of culture just like
Natasha's version of the peasant dance
that's not to say that Russian culture
is just an intellectual construction in
those sort of jargon istic terms they've
fashionable to cultural historians these
days
Russia was more than a discourse there
was a real Russia that was real enough
there was a historic Russia there was a
landscape of physical Russia and there
was I would say a set of customs and
beliefs a temperament which is
undeniable and it means that Stravinsky
after 50 years of living in the West
could return as we see him here landing
at sharing the age of airport could
return to his homeland or after 50 years
and pick up instinctively just as
Natasha had picked up the dance
instinctively could pick up
instinctively modes of speech social
interaction he could slip in to childish
expressions that
he had not employed for over 50 years so
if it's not my aim to deny this Russia
that there is a real temperament out
there how do we get at it and what do we
make of the myths that build on these
fictive images of what Russian culture
is to answer the second point first I
would say that we need to look at these
at the way artistic myths become
powerful political forces and they do so
in an extraordinary way in Russia if you
think about it all the great cultural
forces are movements of Russia in the
19th century were organized around these
fictive myths effective images of Russia
the slava files with their their myth of
the Russian soul the the Westerners with
their cult of Petersburg the populace
with their notions of the peasant as a
natural socialist or the other Citians
with their view of Russia as an
elemental culture from the Asiatic step
now the point about these misses they're
not just constructions of national
identity they played a crucial role in
shaping the allegiances of Russia's
politics as well as in developing
notions of the self for the most
elevated forms of personal and national
identity to the most quotidian matters
of dress speech interior design and so
on I mean the examples are a classic the
Slava files are a classic case in point
their notion of you know homegrown
Russian Christian principles organized a
new political community in the 19th
century made up largely of the
provincial gentry Moscow intellectuals
many priests and it did many liberal
sections of the bureaucracy and their
politics helped to shape everything from
policies about free trade to foreign
policy to gentry attitudes towards the
peasant and as a cultural movement they
affected the way people dressed the way
they spoke the way they designed their
interiors and so on it was all you know
Bar shoes and onion domes
which itself became I would say one of
the most unhelpful myths about Russian
culture you know the one exported by the
Ballet Russe exotic Russia with its own
mythic image of Natasha's dance one of
the things I would stress is just this
immense complexity of of Russian culture
and indeed its centrality to European
civilization because if you think about
all the great cultural figures of the
19th century the Pushkin's and the tell
stories and the Stravinsky's they are
inextricably both Europeans and Russians
and that sensibility has to be
understood as something complex which
leads me to my second point how we get
at that sensibility and the way I've
tried to do it in the book is to look at
it in terms of custom and convention as
reflected in as many different art forms
as one can both in terms of furniture
clothing but also in terms of the way
they are in articulated in fiction and
in art because eventually we have to
recognize I think that you know we use
this word national identity we use it it
seems to me almost synonymously with the
rather old-fashioned and now politically
incorrect term national character but
what is this it's not something we can
just derive from from works of art and
style and it's it's it's not something
we can make up simply as literary
discourse either if national identity is
to mean anything it must mean behavior
and so what we can actually use
prescriptive literature for what we can
use works of literature and art for
genre painting what we can use Diaries
and letters for and above all memoirs
the tremendously rich tradition of
memoir writing in Russia in the
nineteenth century what we can use all
of this stuff for is to try and get it
at codes of behavior the rituals and
signs of the significance of social
interaction by which these works of art
are are the public meaning of these
works of art is fixed and by which the
inner life of a society is organized
I'm sure you're all aware the I'm going
to finish in just a minute if that's
okay
there are distinct modes of behavior in
for every European Russian there are
moments when they have to act out or as
Peter commanded them to they have to
almost act out their European manners
like an actor on the stage and then
there are other moments perhaps more
informal moments more relaxed moments
when perhaps even unconsciously they can
become more themselves in a Russian
Miglia Natasha's visit to her uncle was
one such switch seems to me or the
picturing of one such switch the way she
was expected to behave at home in in the
rust off palace or at the ball where she
was presented to the Emperor was a world
apart from this village scene where
expressive nature was allowed free reign
and it was evidently a gregarious
enjoyment of such a relaxed social
setting that communicated itself in her
dance this same sense of relaxation of
becoming more oneself in a Russian media
was shared by many Russians of Natasha's
class and generation including her own
uncle it would seem simple recreations
the country house or dacha going into
the woods visiting the bathhouse or what
Nabokov called the very Russian sport of
hadith buggery be hunting for mushrooms
were more than the retrieval of a rural
it'll they were the expressions of one's
Russian Asst so identity is a
fashionable term but it's meaningless
unless we can show how it manifests
itself in behavior and what I've tried
to do then is to interweave through
works of art that might express that
behavior the sort of Diaries and letters
the sort of memoir literature that would
give us something about the way the
Russians saw of a particular class the
literary class of course saw such things
as childhood the way to methods of
child-rearing
or marriage or the way they responded to
death or their response to the landscape
and so on and I've done this because it
seems to me
that these episodes are the place where
we could find perhaps in life the unseen
threads of a common Russian sensibility
such as Tolstoy had imagined in his
celebrated dancing scene
thank you you like to take some
questions from the audience at this
point I want to go ahead and start one
of the themes that you drew out was the
issue of language and I was wondering if
you see that as a being particularly
relevant today with the encouragement of
the English language
yeah African culture yes it is a
parallel isn't it as certainly in terms
of the you know the penetration it is
comparable but even probably more so I
would have thought that penetration of
the English language in Russia today but
in in in in sort of Russia of Tolstoy's
childhood it it was rather more subtle
and complex than that because clearly
okay there are lots of distinctions to
be made I mean in the provinces probably
Russian was more common but in the in
sort of cosmopolitan society which he
was describing in war and peace it
created tremendous polarities and and
confusion because basically you know
that there was a sphere of being
expected to speak quite intimate
thoughts in a foreign tongue from quite
an early age you might recall that scene
in Anna Karenina when I think it's one
of the little Scherbatsky children comes
in while Levin is there and is asking
for a balloon or something something
childish and the mother chides the child
and says you must ask for this in French
which seems too artificial and I think
which is something that might explain
why there was such a nostalgia for those
serf nannies why the by the nanny
becomes such a sort of cult figure in
Russia because it was you know not just
a feminine sphere but it was actually
the sphere where they were introduced to
Russian language and folklore and they
under and and they didn't have to to try
and express themselves in a foreign
tongue but
so there there are complex emotional
divisions there are complex intellectual
traditions there are all sorts of rules
about when you can speak in French and
when you can speak in Russian and I
spent quite there I spent quite a lot of
time trying to look into how it was used
there are two sort of dynasties that run
through the book the shelling mages in
the Valcke on skis and I spent a lot of
time looking at the the letter the
letters of of the valcon ski princes and
it and they slip in and out of Russian
into French with in one sentence an
often the the fascinating thing is a
dolphin they they they go into Russian
from French I detected some sort of
pattern in said gay val conjugate the
Decembrist in any case which might be
indicative because he's a decembrist but
they he switched from French into
Russian when he wanted to insist on his
sincerity or something like that when he
wants to be honest which sort of reminds
me of um it reminds me of that scene in
war and peace when his princess Ln yes
is is trying to face up to the fact
she's going to have to talk about her
infidelities to be Zhukov and she says
how am I can how am I going to put this
meaning obviously what language of mind
speaking and then she decides well it's
so much easier to lie in French yes
right down here microphone will come to
nothing
I was just wondering as you were giving
your talk or the Russian word wit came
to mind breathe yeah and is this what
you're after yeah it yeah you're right
it is if I could have called it yeah I
mean it's it's an attempt to write a
book called cultura abrete okay isn't it
but um you can't how do you put bleach
into English you don't but there is that
extraordinary Russian concept of bleach
and and and an extraordinary
consciousness that it is it is it is
it's not just custom is it it's it's not
just sort of everyday life and it is
integral to what writers do my more I of
Moyes reminded of a as a wonderful line
in Shostakovich is a lady
Beth went up one of the characters says
about goggle he was so good at
describing Russian beat and and so it's
this sense that life is is in the art
and that's what and that descriptive
element of trying to to grasp the
essence of what it all is all about is
in is in the cultura
but yes you're absolutely right it is
cool Toto and boot yes right here on the
side I'd like to suggest that perhaps
the ha lot that Pushkin is wearing is
not from the peasant but it's the same
one that the French and the Americans at
about the same time yes
used to define and intellectual that you
had yourself pictured miss Barragan art
historian from the Portrait Gallery has
written on it about two years ago oh
wait I love the Reston thing that you
don't wear your own clothes right where
it essentially a sort of academic robe a
Greek yes yes yeah yes so it's that sort
of Grecian thing is it changed yes like
Byron and it has another word to which
another title for it
how lots something or other else right
okay it was an artistic convention well
then then the example thank you so much
for putting that can I can I chase you
for a reference afterwards but that yes
that's useful but but so the examples
are bad one perhaps but um but the but
but but that thing of you know you you
read quite often about how the when they
when they will go to the dacha for
example they would wear more relaxed
clothing you know and the whole thing of
a dressing gown
you know the abloom of like oriental
dressing gown sir
yeah the muscovite thing and and it's
also the interesting thing here too I
think is that there's very little
distinction often although I don't think
it's consciously a lack of distinction
between what is relaxed Russian and what
is relaxed oriental you know is a Blom
of being Russian or Asiatic when he's in
his dressing gown is when they talk
about the Scythian temperament the you
know when hurts and says I'm a true Sith
and I which is my right to be savage and
uncivilized and uncultivated that is the
same they you could apply that to the
Asiatic
in the Russian way that is cars just as
much as one could apply in fact for the
Russian temperament as it might be cast
in counter distinction to the to the
European behavior as expected but but
thank you for that reference is very
interesting okay you can ask if you have
a question to raise your hand and leave
it up for a second all I get areas
bearings okay we have four questions
left in about 15 minutes over here to a
second I'm Boris logical Kendall Canaan
scholar sorry
um was um the essence of your book
cultura Ebert culture and boot or
cultura culture against boot ah why
Russians struggle against boot and more
often against culture in the whole
history so you're you're you're
referring to so the distinction should
in Boyton beach ii or the transcendence
of beat as being yeah oh I see well well
but yes both I mean I think they have a
complex relationship as you suggest
don't know that but because there's
there's this element of of actually so
much of what goes into Russian you know
art forms once or another is a
reflection of boot and is a sort of
digestion of butoh reflection on boot
and at the same time there's this um
there's this striving to transcend boot
to something more meaningful
which Svetlana boom has made a lot of I
think quite persuasively actually the
notion that that that Russian that
there's that there's there's there's a
tempter to transcend the posh list of
breat as as good as Gogol might might
put it and and to and to achieve some
sort of higher moral truth and there
there is that there is that element and
one might be almost tempted to to link
it not just a sort of mysticism
generally or transcendentalism or
religious ideas generally but also to
the sense
that you get in so much Russian
literature don't you of basically the of
the Russia of the provinces being some
sort of hellhole really is some sort of
place which is which is you got to get
out of it because it's just it's just a
what results he called it the
all-russian bog and there is that sort
of sense of needing to transcend care
next question is on the side here it's
actually a short comment I'm sorry for
micro criticism but they cure another a
lot to mention okay you showed us image
of ghostly player yeah but as I could
see and if I'm correct he was playing
not ghostly but modification of kabsa
which is the instrument string
instrument played with the help of
revolving hand ah so it's a sort of
mechanized yeah I am NOT a movie musical
historian but I believe that it's better
to consult yeah this image with a
musical historian because yeah you know
the devil is in details sure sure no
gear I will on the back of the
photograph which came from the Russian
museum of ethnography was ghostly player
but I should go back to them and say my
friend says it's not but you're quite it
might maybe obviously in the late 19th
century there were more and more
mechanized forms as you're suggesting
coming in Ukraine but becoming common
for the Sauser and region of Russia
right right yeah yeah yeah thank you
thank you for that okay right here turn
on the jacket could you comment on the
role of religion in the organized Church
yeah in the evolving configuration of
the national identity show with pleasure
yeah I will I see it a central obviously
I I would though say I'm I'm
particularly interested in it's often
said isn't it the church is the one
unifying force and I suppose in many
ways it is the one unifying force rather
than the state in many ways but I'm also
impressed by the fact that actually
in especially in the late 19th century
the church looks very fragile in other
ways too because of the huge growing
spread of the sect I mean recent work
now suggesting that the sectarians were
many many more than we had thought
before and and looking researching into
the whole thing about this about the
church and tell story and the and the
conflicts over excommunication I see a
church actually which is quite which is
quite some which is quite defensive
about about it and worried about its
ability to actually play that national
unifying force so I would I would I
would say that the churches are sort of
instant as a established Church so we
say is perhaps not as it's Rob's
important but it's not certainly not as
spiritually alive as the broader search
for for religious truth for more
informal types of orthodoxy which which
we know at the the you know as in dust I
have Sookie's Karamazov the you know
that the Alexa hue goes beyond the
monastery walls I think those religious
searchings which are tremendously
influential not just on writers and all
the rest but but very influential
socially in terms of all those God
seekers and it's all those people who
went off in search of kingdoms of a
poner and all the rest of it or all of
that religious seeking is a very
powerful social force and a very
powerful element in in in the national
consciousness but I would put it i would
i would spread it much wider than just
the walls of the church i think ok we
have a few of course let's um we'll go
to the gentleman back and then we'll
move up to the front of you mentioned
the introduction of the study of grammar
i assume you meant for the children or
the upper class but did the peasants at
that time get all the endings in the
cases right it's such a plague a plague
for us to worry about that
the peasants speaking the truth with all
grammar lined up properly that's really
hard to say because the the philologists
who took an interest in in in in
whatever form of plain speech they could
write down as far as I know didn't take
a interest in in in the grammar being
used by by peasants of different
localities they were just trying to
record like key day of skin others they
were just trying to record the actual
content of tales and things like that as
so it would be rather difficult to tell
later on people like in the cross off
become interested in those elements and
introduced I mean it's seen as an MMO by
people like to gain of trying to
introduce the plain speech into poetry
but but in the crass of does quite a lot
of work on on on on the sort of grammar
used in dialect as I suppose how he
would see it but maybe someone in the
room knows more about this but as far as
I'm aware that we don't we can't
actually tell much about about
differences in Engram grammatical and
syntactical
yes it was it was it was something that
you don't see very often well it's you
don't see very often in the in the late
18th century set Russian grammar and
more importantly perhaps set rhetoric as
a discipline to be introduced to the
curriculum of a well-educated Petersburg
nobleman destined for the civil service
and I think that is a very important
sort of cultural shift around that time
that the Russian is obviously something
that people that are aesthetic people
think is going to be important for for
service culture okay we have time for
two more questions about to come back on
it I don't know do you want to come back
do you want to come back on it related
would you think the best that you can
translating breat into English or French
or German or think ah I thought
rigea what way of life I spy his boot
yeah yeah bout crews next question thank
you my question is only about the
methodology of writing about national
culture and an empire so following on
the horses question yeah what does the
vice appear between Auto Sky cultura and
recei sky haha Wow a for example you've
written a long wonderful book but to
push you further on the length and scope
of the project is Ukraine part yeah or
god yes well obviously I had to make a
decision that fairly early on whether I
was going to be talking about Ruska
cultura ciske things and I decided that
actually what interested me was rosca
and for reasons I can I can I can I can
explain ii-in in relation to the Soviet
period too because I wanted to see what
was really at the heart of holding a
people together rather than what what
were official forms of culture although
obviously that's not to deny that the
Imperial identity has been very powerful
one particularly within Petra and
civilization that's undeniable on the
question of the of the Ukraine that
means that or indeed any other area that
means I've had to make sacrifices I mean
there's just it's not comprehensive
history I mean how could one do that I
mean it's it's some pretty comprehend
its it's pretty fat we managed to get
thinner than that to deceive readers in
the British edition but yeah it's
obviously a selective it's a selective
history you know I mean there's people I
don't like or don't get in there but as
far as it means in terms of the national
question
it means inevitably that I have spoken a
little bit about the Russian fascination
with Ukrainian culture as a sort of you
know southern thing so you know the
reason why goggles early tales were so
popular but I haven't actually looked at
Ukrainian culture and how it's all
Russian culture or how since indeed 91
it's tried to extricate itself from
Russian countries or things a very
interesting question
and so it means that you know the
caucuses are there but only insofar as
they are a you know part of a rush
myth of the caucuses so I yeah so that's
what I've done
Orlando Fox is author of Natasha's dance
it's published by metropolitan books a
division of Henry Holton company visit
Henry Holt calm for more information